hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game from round 5 of this
year's Global chess League Java
Christina versus pragnananda and they
will treat us to a very special line of
the Italian game uh if you're wondering
what happened on board one at Maxima
shellegar has defeated Magnus Carlsen
and now uh the Alpine Warriors are in
trouble uh they need the they need to
bounce back in order to uh to equalize
with the Mumbo Masters I believe uh the
the name is and uh well it's not gonna
be easy but it's it's a crazy game you
guys will enjoy it let's check it out so
joking has the white pieces and he opens
with E4 uh Prague replies with ponte5
Knight F3 Knight to C6 and now Bishop to
C4 uh Bishop to C5 going for the Joker
piano as a reply to the Italian game and
now I know you guys will not believe
this but here uh Knight the C3 was
played and this is uh this just when I
saw this I was like wow the point point
is that here the standard moves are C3
D3 C3 and castles those are the top
moves and the fourth most popular option
here is of course B for the Evans Gambit
Knight the C3 is only the fifth most
popular option and this is what Java is
uh trying to use to beat the pregnant
the idea will be once Prague develops
the Knight he will trade his Knight
immediately for the Knight on F6 and
okay it has been attempted before by
some very strong players like kramnik
played a short player fedos have played
it even Daniel dubov played it so okay
it can be played but I if you're not
going for the top three continuations I
mean the Evans Gambit is right there but
okay Knight to F6 we transfer into the
Four Knights game uh we have D3 A6 and
now Knight to D5 we have Knight captures
Bishop captures and here uh Prague just
uh castles we have Castles by Java kit
as well D6 and noun uh there is the game
where Bishop to G5 was played but here
we have Pawn to C3 and it is now as of
move 9 that we have a completely new
game so Queen to F6 Pro continues
development with Ponte A4 we have Ponte
A5 now stopping B4 uh pretty much
indefinitely and Ponte H3 we have Pawn
to H6 and Bishop back to B3 now the
bishop can be shifted over to C2 end
later on maybe some pawns will be pushed
maybe this bishop can become useful so
Bishop back to A7 are also a very
standard idea and now Bishop to E3 with
Bishop to E6 and here we have uh the
tension between both Bishop pairs this
does not have a name in chess but I
think it should have a uh well at least
a very cool name so if you have any
ideas of how we should call uh such a uh
such a position in chess do share it in
the comment section Rook D1 uh we have
some trades here Bishop captures will
capture is not interested in messing up
his spawn structure Rook 8 to d8 and
Bishop captures an E6 Prague also
captures with the queen later on uh
depending on what white plays you will
either play F6 or even F5 so D4 striking
in the center preparing Pawn to D5 to
win some material and now Knight to E7
we have Queen to E2 preparing to bring
the other Rook into the game and pawn to
C6 with Queen back to C2 now uh and
Knight the G6 now the Knight is coming
to
uh F4 and then you will have constant
pressure on that H3 Pawn so okay Rook to
D1 there's I mean it's best not to react
to this Rook after E8 and not King the
H2 and finally Knights the F4 and now it
makes it a bit difficult to get rid of
the Knight because if G3 is played then
immediately Queen captures an H3
followed by Queen to G2 this will be
Checkmate so okay Rook to D2 it's not
that proc can make use of this uh at any
point or Rook a queen to C7 uh and now
Queen to B3 now being a very annoying
against this F7 pawn and Prague would
also like to get his King to a bit of a
safer Square so Queen to C7 defending
the F7 pawn and okay now you are no
longer pressuring this H3 Pawn uh so
Java kill gets rid of the Knight G3 we
have Knight back to E6 and now Pawn to
H4 we have e Captain D4 C captures and
finally Pawn to D5 and as usual if black
can execute the central thrust with Pawn
to D5 uh he is well uh at least the
equal so we have Pawn the E5 which okay
white grabs more space in the center but
you know that C5 is coming it will
undermine the D4 Pawn then D5 Pawn
becomes weak uh and so on yeah that's
exactly what Prague does immediately C5
uh Rook to C3 stopping the capture for
the moment and just Queen to E7 uh Queen
to B6 uh saying okay once we trade
everything I'm gonna capture on A5 and
okay Knight captures on the four Knight
capture C captures and The Rook capture
Sunday for prop captures on E5 and now
uh you can capture right away as The
Rook here would hang so Rook C to D3
first putting more pressure on the D5
pawn and now Rook to D6 chasing away the
queen and now uh which Pawn would you
capture it's a very uh difficult moment
to react to especially in uh with little
time on the clock uh the engine says
Queen captures on B7 is the more precise
move because you can equalize it much
easier and you will have a triple attack
against this D5 pawn and okay if you
guys are interested in the exact line
Queen captures on B7 uh Black's plan in
all of the lines here is go Rook F6 put
pressure on the F2 pawn and now if Rook
D2 you can immediately play Rook
captures and F2 with check recapture
Queen captures on D4 Queen captures on
F7 with checking to H7 and okay now you
can either Force some sort of Perpetual
with Queen to F5 or you play King to G2
the game continues but it's an equal
position however after progs Rook to the
six Queen captures and A5 was played by
Joker and now it is a bit different Rook
Dev 6 Again by Prague and Rook to D2
most likely expecting proc to just play
Rook captures on F2 check file by Rook
cap a queen captures Rook on D4 however
he just uh builds up the tension Queen
to E1 and it is the correct way to do it
uh this way uh as now you also uh pretty
much paralyzed The Rook here as the
queen on A5 is undefended so okay how do
you how do you react to this there's
only one move that the white can play
and that is Queen captures on D5
anything else you try you just collapse
so Queen captures on D5 is played and
now Rook captures an F2 check Rook
captures Queen captures an F2 with check
King to H3 and now Rook the E3 uh
threatening Queen captures and G three
Checkmate and now you have to be very
precise on how you go about this
and uh well Joker blunder the game here
I should have played Queen to G2 this
stops everything uh you know it doesn't
look like a great position but after
some like Queen to F5 checking H2 and
let's say G5 which is Black's uh best
attempt at going after the white king
you will play Rook D2 prepare Rook to F2
and that's pretty much it like G
captures G captures uh this comes with
check you will move the king if Rook F2
okay you can throw in a nice check Queen
E5 check but now King H1 and if rookie
one check you have Rook to F1 uh nothing
to worry about your equal material uh
okay black will will be at least a
little bit better uh Black's King is a
bit safer here but you know all in all
should be a draw however in the game
Rook the G4 was played uh this is how he
defended the G3 Pawn but of course you
guys know that this simply doesn't work
because of a very very simple reason
Queen to F1 check was played now of
course if you go King to H2 uh then Rook
D to check and that's it you have to
block with the queen and queen captures
and G2 will be Checkmate so of course
Joker played Queen to G2 he defended but
now now I'm sure you guys already see
what the problem with this plan is but
in case not feel free to pause the video
and win the game for Prague while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on realizing that
the rook and king are aligned on the
same diagonal and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Queen
to F5 and as soon as Brock played this
of course Java can realize that the game
is over because H5 is simply Unstoppable
uh he found a way to prolong the game a
little bit he played Queen to D2 so okay
now I've played H5 we also pick up the
Rook uh but Prague just played Rook to
E4 Now The Rook is again hanging he
defended it with Queen to D1 and here uh
Prague just played Ponte H5 and he was
in this position on move 41 that the
Java christinderella resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here okay you could throw in a nice
spite check here with Queen to d8 but
after that I mean there's there's no
more moves whatever you play you just
get completely destroyed for those of
you who are maybe uh completely new to
chess the game might continue with some
level at the queen G5 you know don't
even have to capture The Rook you can
just deliver a very quick Checkmate
Queen to F1 checking H2 and Rook to E2
will will be Checkmate but it's so
winning that it really doesn't matter
what you play you you could play
whatever you want your cat could
continue the game for you here and uh I
mean you would still yeah you would
still win after this
um uh a pawn to H5 move uh so yeah very
nicely done by Prague and this also
means that even though Magnus lost on
board one to Maxima Shiela Graf and all
of the other games were drawn at Prague
one again cinderov and that means that
Alpine Warriors Drew their match against
the upgrad Mamba Masters so very nicely
done by Prague
and you know he brings one in for the
team
hmm
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank an
anonymous person dog and Repcon uh one
but Houston uh Thomas veterly Dan
McCormick and James Eugene Cashman for
your contribution to my channel thank a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and in case
some of you are not receiving
notifications when I publish a video you
can always join our telegram Channel and
then uh you know you will instantly be
notified whenever I publish a video it
will be the first link in the
description below uh thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day